all right everybody let's jump into this
first story we got it from the
huffington post you know how much we
love them post alexandrio ocasio-cortez
has pithy reply when asked if she'll run
for president the popular progressive
house member had just watched cassidy
hutchinson's testimony of the january 6
hearing when colbert popped the question
that's right they're getting married
everybody
aoc i'm kidding so he asks her he's like
this is really really funny because he
roasted joe biden at the same time so
respect for that
uh
they don't actually no they don't
actually show what he said about colbert
that's funny he said no matter how many
times people ask joe biden if he's gonna
run for reelection and he says yes they
ignore what he says and then ask other
people to run
so the new york times actually ran this
article check this out biden irked by
democrats who won't take yes for an
answer on 2024. yo it's not about taking
yes for an answer it's about how even if
you say yes they're like dude's brain
doesn't work so there they don't think
he's gonna run anyway
so here's the best part
colbert is like i know someone who's
going to turn 35 and uh right before the
election ha ha could it be you and then
she said listen we need to keep we need
to focus on keeping democracy for
anybody to be present in the next couple
of years she replied my central focus is
helping the people of this country right
now so it's possible i don't know about
that
well i don't think she's actually going
to run but the fact that on prime time
tv stephen colbert is asking her if she
will i think what we're seeing you had
cnn say hillary it's her time now did
you see that article from chris saliza
then everyone made fun of her this is
hilarious one of her uh her former
campaign strategist came out and said
her polling is actually her numbers our
ratings are worse than trump's
so he's like no no no no no hillary no
she's not coming back
i think the democrats in the estate in
the corporate press they're desperate to
try and find
someone
i think the goal of asking aoc is so
that they drop the stone in the water to
see where the ripples go they make the
statement and now they want to see how
the press handles it and what the
reaction from the public is yes they
never said she's gonna run but what
happens if all of a sudden people start
saying yeah aoc should run and there's
big fervor and fire under it then
they'll be like oh oh yeah okay so
they're testing the waters trying to see
who they can get and i got to be honest
when i heard that they asked that
colbert asked if she'd run
i'm like out of all the democrats that
are available she'd beat them all save
michelle obama maybe but
gavin knew some aoc would do better well
i think there's there's an important
point here so if the democrats know
anything that they're starting to
realize that they don't have that much
of a shot in 2024 if trends continue
there's not much hope for their party
right now and so it could be possible
that what they would plan on doing is
putting up some throwaway candidate in
2024 whose anti-establishment and
actually relatively popular with their
base so that next time an election comes
along when a democrat actually does
stand a chance of winning they can go we
tried this anti-establishment person the
people weren't interested they lost
we're not going to run them or they can
use as an opportunity to raise aoc's
profile that too right now she's just a
popular house member she's not a senator
she's not that big a presidential
campaign run where they expect to lose
can can push her up to a very prominent
public space at the national level am i
in this conversation already absolutely
yeah jump in okay good
uh we got to debunk this right now i
can't i can't stand it
this whole facade that aoc is
anti-establishment oh yeah fair enough
fair enough it's a complete scam they
want a runner as anti-establishment
exactly i want to say that exactly the
deploy that they're running is that
when you say you're socialist then
you're anti-corporate
but when you plan to expand socialism to
the global scale it's the ultimate form
of corporatism yeah i would agree and
also there's nothing aoc believes that
our public education system has not been
set up to brainwash children into
believing so i know i totally agree with
him she eats out of the palm of the
establishment but she's viewed as an
outsider but if they don't then i wanted
to say if they
if they don't win in 2024 it's over
because the young america first populous
movement that's on the rise
is going to go in and crush
the old narrative that allowed an aoc to
pose as anti-corporate and it's all
mostly predicated on
one the story of blacks historically in
the country that's kind of the lynchpin
of grievance politics and
anti-establishment but also the young
people who are indoctrinated at schools
and if the conservatives win in the
midterms in 2024
we got to go back and take those schools
i think we're headed towards a um
there's a strong possibility of hyper
racialization happening in the next
several years there was a viral thread
where this uh this dude said
you know uh there are young white men in
school being told that they're the
oppressors then they see that most
people in college are female then they
see that
like you know when they apply for a job
they're like we're not hiring any white
men and so this is a big thread where
they explain that
you know maybe it applies to older white
men because when those older white men
were younger they were the majority and
they controlled a lot of the space but
now that it's inverted younger white men
are growing up being told that they're
the evil oppressors but they're getting
held back and they're getting restrained
so they're getting angry and they're
forming racial identitarian groups or
they're starting to coalesce around race
so the left
in pushing this stuff i think is
hyper-racializing everything 100 100
what they're banking on is that white
people are always going to
self-flagellate every single time a
discussion on racial issues comes up
because that's sort of been the status
quo but ultimately at some point white
guilt runs out
so it's it's generational it's
generational memory
uh what people don't understand when it
comes to politics they talk about like
the pay gap right yeah but for which
demographic the pay gap exists for sure
among boomers the pay gap exists among
millennials but it's inverted millennial
women make more money than millennial
men millennial women are more likely to
graduate college than millennial men yet
they keep pushing a narrative as if it's
the younger generation suffering what
the older generation went through and
that's going to cause a serious problem
because in these stories whether it's
about uh leftist racial unitarianism
creating more white identitarianism or
social issues that were relevant 50
years ago not being relevant today and
then punishing young people today based
on the grievances of the past you are
going to raise a generation with an
inverted
system which causes oppression which
causes anger and animosity the only
difference is
right now they're telling the young
majority white males that they're evil
and oppressors and then restricting them
but these young young men don't know
anything about the civil rights movement
they didn't experience that they weren't
part of it the only thing about slavery
jim crow they weren't a part of it they
don't think about the klan they don't
they they're not alive during a time of
the clan and they weren't a part of it
but they're still the majority so what
happens when you when you raise a the
majority and and tell them that they're
evil oppressors and you take from them
you make it harder for them
yo they're going to come out in force
they're going to vote in force and then
it's really going to flip pendulum is
going to swing hard the other direction
a bunch of kids that believe they're
evil oppressors grow up to become evil
oppressors no that's not what i'm saying
well that's going to happen i'm saying
that
it's possible a lot of them do
it's that this this you know 17 year old
white kid is like they're you said
there's a pay gap why do all the women
make more money you said you said that
men are privileged how come i can't get
a job you say that matter of privilege
how come the women are the ones who are
graduating from college right how is it
me because they do not live in the
generations past this this thing where
people are telling us one thing but it's
not right like that the economy is doing
great when you have like the the speaker
it's driving people crazy it's driving
me crazy it's got to be driving young
people crazy because they don't have the
context i have at least the outlet i
have for the most part not that all of
them don't but i mean it's got to be
driving people insane
that's dangerous my my concern about the
entire race conversation that i've been
thinking about more recently is
the concept of white itself
i don't like it i totally agree but what
do you mean by that well
i'm irish
what i mean is it's true there's there's
a bit of a double cross and triple cross
when it comes to saying who's white
i mean barack obama was white
what i mean is
you know
in in europe let's say for example is
white sorry nobody nobody calls
themselves white you're from spain
you're from romania you're from
uh italy you're from the uk your irish
whatever the case may be
in america we've kind of been the
driving force of creating a a
you know unified
white identity that's an amalgamation of
a bunch of european clans that used to
oppress and kill each other and that
framework of history gets completely
lost on young people we still do for
sure
but but that exactly yeah well the
russians aren't even considered white
and modern they're they're slavs but
yeah yeah slavics are people of color
apparently they are people covered yeah
like our friend lucas yeah yeah so but
that but it just it just shows you that
the the history uh is is something
that's lost on on many people in its
premise
as you mentioned your problem with the
concept of white i i agree luke
rudkowski has blonde hair and blue eyes
yeah but he's slavic so they say he's a
person of color and i'm just like all
right you lost me dude yeah no it's
completely absurd i've said this before
the idea of just like one wholesale
white identity erases the different
ethnic groups that actually fall under
that umbrella and it's interesting how
that definition has changed over time
historically in this country it was
basically a label that was used to
exclude catholics it was all of the
people who had white skin but were from
catholic cultures who were considered
non-white so the irish the polish the
italians and now today
irish people are considered white but
irish people weren't considered white
until being white men you had to
apologize for being white all the time
well so this is this is actually the
left's argument that's what it is their
argument is that white changes
that italian people weren't considered
white therefore white whiteness today
doesn't really mean the color of your
skin it means like your ideas social
you know the washington post said that
i'm a far-right white nationalist now
they're going to start calling black
people
cheers they're going to start calling
black people who are america first larry
elder yeah you're white owens clarence
thomas it's like it's like it dave
chappelle's skit has come to life
clayton was it clayton bixby yeah yeah i
can't you know dave you're a prophet how
is this how is this real life it's
almost like he manifested it he made the
skit thinking like this i'll make
something so crazy it'll never work you
know the fascinating thing about that
clayton bigsby segment was it showed
that it was about culture and ideas more
than race that in his bit the point
being made was that the white
supremacists were like he's such a good
speaker and his ideas are so beneficial
to us we gotta we gotta keep him around
and then there was the scene where he
sees he hears the rap music and it's
three white guys and then he calls him a
racial slur and they liked it because
they were trying to people right they're
like cool
yeah like the the point was interesting
is that it was about culture not about
race
and i think that that actually is still
true today
but you know i agree with you but they
wanna they wanna have it both ways right
so the left wants to talk about this
idea of a white identity and um they'll
claim that whiteness changes over time
and it's an arbitrary construct but then
they'll turn around and go you have
white skin you are objectively white
therefore i don't have to listen to your
opinion exactly dave chappelle was also
brilliant in that and when he said he
made the joke that people in the lgbtq
like to claim that they're minorities
until it was time to be white right
like when he made the skit about the
cops being called and yeah nobody nobody
who's black and trans says oh well my
name is clifford because when the cop
shows up they don't care who which one
of you is clifford they you know if you
have blacks basically he was saying that
black skin is an immutable quality
and gender identity is not immutable
yeah well so this is something i i used
to bring this up because one argument
that was always made around 10 years ago
is that like oh you know the um question
of homosexuality and homosexual unions
and lgbtq rights is like the racial
struggle of our day it's the civil
rights struggle and that's completely
absurd i mean first of all like there's
no in the closet if you're black right
right like you're just black everywhere
it's it's completely different it's
completely different but they want
because it's understood that it's a
powerful rhetorical tool because
americans care a whole lot about race if
you want people to be sympathetic to a
group of people you say look what's
happening to them is just like what
happened black people historically
they mentioned that this is like the
civil rights fight of our day they say
things like you know sheamus you would
have been on the side of jim crow and
slavers and it's like it's like no
catholics were not yeah and it's not
just that it's that like we're
effectively dissidents in the to the
establishment we are opposing the
established order you guys are in favor
of what walmart wants right but it's not
the civil rights fight of our day
because none of it makes sense
like when larry elder comes out and he
says here's what i think we can do for
black families and they go you're a
white supremacist i'm like bro you're a
white person calling a black man a white
supremacist because you don't like his
politics it's ridiculous you're not
fighting for civil rights you're just an
egotist who doesn't like the fact that
your your cudgel racism doesn't work or
make sense the same things with candace
owens
black white supremacists no
neither they're neither that's that's
insane they're just people with ideas
you don't like well the people who they
think are white supremacists aren't
white supremacists let alone the black
people being white supremacists but the
other the other interesting historical
piece of this that i think paints this
cultural appropriation that the lgbtq
movement is doing goes all the way back
to the black panthers and fred hampton
fred hampton was the original creator
and founder of the rainbow coalition
and it wasn't until nine years after he
died that the artist from california
took the rainbow icon and used it for
the lgbtq and what most people don't
talk about when they talk panthers or
fred hampton or the rainbow coalition
is that the white organization that was
a part of the three organizations that
that made up the rainbow coalition were
the young patriots and guess what their
icon was the confederate flag
wow they were southerners
let me ask you let me ask you something
so they decided to change the i remember
they changed the pride flag and they
added a black and brown stripe no clue
what it means don't ask me it's it's for
black and brown people no it's not
that's what they said yeah yeah but i'm
just i'm just like is it if this flag is
for lesbian gay bisexual and trans
is it did they add another they add
another b to it for black
so it's lgbtqbb why are black and brown
people in the lgbt flag like what's the
incineration
right i don't understand this stuff
right now well it's also i've said this
before on the show but it's the design
is so stupid because for like the
different sexual identities they want
these different colors of the rainbow to
represent something abstract and it's
like what is the brown for it's like
brown people it was the black or black
people like wait they were fine
but like why didn't they get creative
colors why did everyone else get they
added a white triangle to it did they
really yeah they did yeah learning that
they're right for white people rainbows
from the rainbow coalition which was a
multicultural thing makes a lot more
sense well the rainbow was well the
rainbow coalition was initially
um
fred hampton although the black panthers
had this marxist-leninist
uh philosophical background
uh fred hampton was kind of an anomaly
in chicago and he had his own
you know
version of the black panthers you could
say and and that was the rainbow
coalition in which he kind of reoriented
the black panthers focus on the working
class and he said that despite the
racial issues that do exist in america
there is a greater
predation happening on the working class
economically that was the whole motif of
the rainbow coalition was the working
the unity of working class whites blacks
and latinos so each color and the
original pride flag like represented
some idea yeah and i think they actually
had magic in there and then they were
like we should yeah we should get rid of
the magic from this flag that makes
sense and then um i don't understand the
only thing i understand is how like is
there a committee that decides when the
flag should be changed because one day
people were just like hey we added black
and brown and then everyone started
making these these flags with a black
and brown stripe then they were like
okay actually we're going to put the
trans triangle in the side
and we're going to put the black and
brown in the triangle instead
and then someone was like we should put
a yellow triangle in there too and a
purple circle
now all of a sudden those flags are
flying everywhere but like who decided
that would be the flag like you know
what i mean she's like did you start
making it what is it gonna look like in
two years well the joke is that the the
the trans triangle is pushing the
rainbow out
because it's gradually taking up more
and more space
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there